the Joe Rogan experience look at that
[ __ ] we were just the bone of the food
chain weren't we Oh as soon as we
invented the fire wasn't it so you
discovered the fire boom change control
of fire probably helped weapons Flint
yeah that's it we came first we just
have to scraps when we leftovers from
lions do you feel when you're doing
these tracks and you're going on these
these journeys and you're walking
through places like Mongolia that are
incredibly wild do you do you try to
like envision what it must have been
like to be an early person yeah all
these amazing resources that you have at
your disposal to help you get to this
air everything going - yeah oh it would
be a whole different kit and everything
like so in Mongolia didn't he actually
even use like GPS because that failed me
yeah all communities were in different
places it just didn't work I went back
to boxed and it's map and compass but
you imagine even before then as well map
and compass you say a fold-up map yeah
let's get out yeah we we worth no no no
again boxed and it low-budget journey
that the Mongolia one was so on so if
you lost your map you'd be [ __ ] yeah
that but also the the track that I was
on as I said that you can be following
goat track or camel track and now is
your lifeline that leads you to the next
water source so if you're in a desert
store for example it made more sense to
try to keep going well no just try to
count down hide under your shelter if
you lose sight of the track keep going
yeah so if you just walk at night as
well a lot of people say well it's hot
during the day and he's suffering with
dehydration why didn't you walk at
nighttime you've got the Amur pit vipers
smokes you stand on the back end of them
because you don't see it you you're
pretty screwed but you've also got the
tracks you need to be able to see in the
distance the tracks button off because
you'll come across almost like a
junction four to five different trucks
are splitting off do they really need
your map and compass to be like well
which one which tracks should I go down
you know terrified oh my god I can't
even imagine and you can't communicate
if you come across if you're lucky to
come across locals as well put you in
the wrong no we point you in their
community which that's after
often you'll try to go east and say no I
want to go that way no no mixed
communities this way so I don't want the
next community I want to walk to the
most Eastern you know so it's difficult
but yeah that was always a threat the
dehydration in Mongolia really terrified
me you know what happens if a stand
storm commerce the track up if yeah back
to you map and compass and just hoping
that you can be aware of the people
around you open you've got enough water
hoping you make it to another community
or Selman where as the jungle harsh
environment that you know and spiders
wise snake wise etc but at the same time
always got water you can hack in the
bamboo and it just leaks out water you
know you always got food does anybody
know where you are yeah I had a tracking
device and especially for mission
Yangtze because it was beginners world
record we had set off a tracker and
every five minutes it come up with my
speed so even if I jumped in a car on a
bicycle boom every five minutes it's my
speed it's my altitude my longitude
latitude coordinates the distance
covered whether I'm active and you'll
zoom in and you can see my current
location within five meters and that was
part of the interactivity so I wanted to
make this expedition as interactive as
possible for the full year of like
sharing blogs videos live streams photos
getting people to join again presenting
in schools getting the kids out litter
picking along the Yangtze River doing
the filming for the documentary which
was securing International International
Documentary the mission Yangtze will go
out as so that's exciting so all of this
was very very well planned very in terms
of the interactivity it's like six
months of survival six months of you
know interacting with all the locals and
just sharing again out there as best as
we possibly could
so I was heavily on the radar with GPS
systems the track isn't a lot
[Applause]